okay hello folks welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics
rationally everybody else moves Concepts
around okay and um today we have a great
day we're going to be doing uh the
gravitational constant G
what in the world is that not so much
what it is but what does it represent
from a physical point of view what's the
significance the meaning of it okay
that's that's the
question uh then we're going to answer a
couple questions at the end of the show
but we're going to begin again as we
always do with our Extinction segment
I'm going to show you a little video I
want you to watch it it's some chimps
from one troop
attacking and murdering
raping those of another uh troop okay
here it goes watch
carefully chimps are chasing this uh
female chimp
around and she manages to escape after
struggling with them okay there she goes
and they kill another one and they eat
them they kill a little uh
defenseless one on the other side okay
here you see them
coming
okay great show
huh and people might say well you know
um these are just chimps you know
they're
animals and here we are we're we're
almost no different in fact I'd say
we're not at all any different we're
we're monkeys okay here you have uh
Hamas attacked people in Israel killed a
whole bunch of people took some of them
hostages now the other side comes in and
they want to beat up the Arabs over
there because of what they did just
killing War how are we
different and U how does this relate to
Extinction well you know I'm I'm a
little concerned because as uh I've said
before um the big problem here is if the
economy of the United States falls
apart it's uh too big to fail okay so if
the United States ever the economy of
the United States ever flounders we're
all dead because so many countries in
the world depend on the United States
okay and not only China China happens to
fall maybe something similar would
happen but I think the United States is
a bigger economy especially Europe
depends a lot on it and if the US
economy fails the um European economy
would fall right with it and that would
be just too big really too big to
fail and so what's the issue the issue
is we had a war Ukraine that was a
pretty bad War it was affecting the
global economy it was affecting the
economy of the United States now
apparently we're opposed
to uh inv
uh Hamas and what that's going to do is
create a war with probably the whole
Arab world that's uh two Wars that would
take place more or less at the same time
these I think would be big Wars okay and
uh don't put it past them but the
Chinese said you know they uh they're
going to wait another four years until
they're better prepared uh to attack
Taiwan but you know they might uh uh
jump the gun you know and decide to
attack Taiwan during all this halalu
that's going on this big mess that's
going on so uh we might have a third
world war in uh in a different scenario
you know in the different context where
we have you know a war with China over
there the United States against China a
war between the United States in the
Arab world and a war against Russia so
uh that's stretching at thin for the
military but we're not worried about
that we're worried about what happens to
the economies of every country in the
world and that's what I think you should
think about okay anyways uh I talked
about uh John Talon and his experiment
he ran an experiment with four uh
couples of mice and he let them multiply
in that uh enclosure there they
multiplied and after several months he
got a over
2,200 uh mice in there all descending
from the same grandfathers okay and uh
so what's the issue here well the issue
is that the last
mice uh the last generation of mice lots
of them were U homosexual and autistic
as um Jon you know described them and he
used the phrase he said
uh he he said in his report you know uh
they stop being mice you know when you
you see a normal mice mouse he goes
around does his thing you know tries to
hide tries to hunt you know tries to do
normal things have sex with the females
Etc none of this happened at the end the
end they were all just you
know what he called autistic okay and um
so all I can tell you is that uh you
have to look at the variables and I
think the main variable is the um
Pioneers you know the grandfathers that
gave birth to all of them they all
descended from those same
grandfathers um the grandfathers
themselves probably did not have great
genetic diversity after thousands maybe
millions of years that the mice have
been around you know so the mice that
you see in the labs you probably check
their DNA and they all or their
chromosomes Etc and they're probably all
clones in a certain way you know uh so
that's bad starting point to begin with
but then you know you put them in this
enclosure and they multiply they all
come from the same parents you have the
founders effect um add to that the fact
that uh you know they've got this
density in there that's increasing day
by day that's got an effect as well so I
think uh you when you look at all these
variables
uh you say well okay I can see why uh he
ended up with mice that had mental
problems okay now one fell says well he
doesn't believe that what he saw or what
he what kahun did uh was um autism you
know that he did not observe autism in
mice and he says the following says I
don't think Calhoun's experiments
adequately demonstrate autism being
created in the lab uhhuh okay there were
some mice who became asocial and stayed
away from the others okay I don't think
that's necessarily autistic there's been
some talk coming from these two other
guys I know that autism is not a dis
genic condition but a vestigial
psychology okay so what is he talking
about well here's uh uh the first part
of that uh this genic
okay and um says uh this the definition
decrease recent prevalence of traits
considered to be either socially
desirable or well adapted to their
environment due to selective pressure
this favoring the reproduction of those
traits okay but there's uh this uh
psychologist and he's the guy who kind
of worked on this you know trying to
make a case for it he says in his book D
genics argued that a reduction in
selection pressures and decreased infant
mortality since the industrial
Revolution he's talking about humans not
mice okay have resulted in an increased
propagation of dous traits and genetic
disorders Lyn lists three concerns
deterioration in health intelligence and
conscientiousness okay Lyn claims that
unlike modern societies natural
selection and pre-industrial societies
favored what traits such as intelligence
and
character okay and he's got detractors
uh here's uh the the other side of the
story people who looked at this as well
okay and they say the following since
the 19th century a race deterioration
has been repeatedly predicted as a
result of the excessive multiplication
of less gifted people nevertheless the
educational and qualification level of
people in the industrialized countries
has risen strongly the fact that the
test
intelligence has also significantly
increased okay there's intelligence has
increased among humans right is
difficult to explain for supporters of
the dysgenic thesis they suspect that
the phenotypic intelligence has
increased for environmental reasons
while the genotypic quality secretly
decreases uh there is neither evidence
nor proof for this Theory
okay am I having problems with the
volume uh I hope I don't have the same
problem I had last time where the uh
robot came
into okay let me know please anyways um
so there are differences of
opinion uh my take on this is that um
there has been a decrease not in
intelligence uh I don't see it from a
intelligence point of view I'm saying
that what has happened is that we've U
lost genetic diversity in the last 200
years uh the human race does not have
uh a great variation in its genetic VI
diversity there was a study I showed it
in the past where you have um a pack of
chimps just like you saw a minute ago
and um maybe hundred of them and they
took the they looked at the um DNA the
uh variation that they had and they said
they had more variation than the entire
human race and we're talking about the
entire human race 8 billion people
people against 100 chimps taken at
random over there in Africa and 100
chimps had more variation than the
entire human race uh every person on the
planet today humans right we're all
alike we're all clones doesn't matter if
you're Japanese African Russian South
American North American Australian we're
all the same we're all clones anyone who
you marry today is either your sister or
your brother from a biological
standpoint and that's got very little to
do with these people talk about they
went out there and they try to look for
evidence of this genics uh meaning they
went in there and they said look uh have
we lost our intelligence are we becoming
Dumber every day or whatever that's not
the point the point is you know what is
our biology that's what I'm referring to
okay and I'm saying that with um Calhoun
observed in his lab when he did this
these experiment he did 30 of them but
this was one of the last ones I think
and what he observed is that the mice
deteriorated very rapidly towards the
end and I don't think he was really
referring to you know how much
intelligence they had or anything like
that even though that was part of his
project I think we're looking at what
happened biologically to those mice
because of founders effect and because
of the uh density crowdedness okay and
that's the way I look at that anyway uh
okay here we so um this F continues and
he says the following he says autistic
people have far more nerve Connections
in their brains than alistic or allistic
uh normal people um I I had it in
reversed uh as far as I'm concerned it's
the other way around as I understand it
there's been a study that shows that
they have fewer Connections in their
brains this fell comes up with far more
nerve connections I don't know uh we
have two different uh facts there okay I
don't know which one is true okay
allistic what is that allism no autistic
means neurotypical that means you're
normal that's all allistic means okay on
the other hand neurotypicals uh anyone
who is not autistic diagnosed with ad
dhds dyslexia etc etc okay so then
you're a normal you're an allistic they
invent these terms I don't know why just
to make things more complicated they
just should say normal period we're done
okay anyways um a study out there that I
looked at I don't have the reference
there brain development in people with
Autism differs from those with typical
neural development these differences are
linked to what
genes
genetics involved in inflammation
immunity response and neural
Transmissions so I continue to insist if
I may that autism is related to um
genetic
chromosomes you know uh I'm not an
expert I can't tell you anything really
about that all look at is the the uh
statistics out there and I do give the
example of the Amish the Amish have been
in the United States for about 350 years
they started out with a small population
I think uh there there's different
numbers out there but around maybe, 1500
would be a a good guess today they're uh
300,000
um
Amish and uh they're having all kinds of
genetic problems why because they've
been in breeding so it's a good
experiment you know uh done by humans
where you have population for 300 years
in breeding and today they're having the
results of some of those they have weird
genetic diseases and what can you say to
that it's it's their genes which are
screwed up because they're all alike
okay that's the way I look at it anyways
um changing the subject a little bit and
in line what we talked about the other
day which was the dinosaurs we have one
fell says huge dinosaurs never existed
just invented no one found a big
dinosaur before
1881 well I don't think this all has his
facts right and again everybody can
believe whatever facts they want you
know and here you have 1677 Robert plot
uh discovered uh Dreer of
Megalosaurus and in 1824 they found an
Iguanodon or parts of him right of this
animal um again you can say well you got
your facts wrong Bill uh you know you
can say whatever you want there's some
things that you that sometimes I
question you know uh about what are we
going to call a fact uh we all we all
know you know we all uh believe that
Napoleon went to waterl in 1815
okay and but none of us have been there
we don't we don't know this we we take
it for granted because it it has been
handed down from generation to
generation to us okay and uh so you know
there's no reason to deny it that
Napoleon went to water even though none
of us were there none of us witnessed it
we just read history and this is what
they tell us where did this information
come from from our forefathers who
recorded these
there's no reason to doubt that and
likewise you know there are certain
facts that you have to accept and some
people deny even some of the most
obvious facts that have no reason to be
um
reinterpreted among them the Flat Earth
I'm sorry to say but
yeah there's no reason to deny the the
uh global Earth the globular globular
Earth you know the roundish Earth uh but
some people do and uh so what are you
going to say you know uh all I can tell
you is the
dinosaurs um you know were there 65
million years ago they at some point
they
disappeared uh about that time 65
million years ago why because their uh
their carcasses their um you know their
bones their whatever uh their fossils
are no longer found in the layer of rock
at that level and so they calculated
more or less how long it took for the
Earth above that point to take they say
well it's 65 million years plus or minus
maybe another million years um and for
these people to say well we never found
uh what a uh a dinosaur before 188s you
know what can I say there these things
are recorded there's no reason to doubt
them that someone found you know
megal Don and iguana Don and whatever
okay there's no reason to doubt that
that okay why would anyone lie about
something like that are they trying to
get their name in lights or something
you know so I don't know what to tell
them here's another uh individual I
think she's a lady and she says uh
humans were around even with the
Dinosaurs we did not live in their
areas absolutely love that you know and
uh yeah I guess um uh they were around
but you but I think she's wrong I think
she uh I think uh we were in the same
area as you can see you know we had our
cars parked next to the
uh to the park at the Jurassic Park so
uh I don't know what to tell her some
people believe these things and and they
really are strongly about have strong
feelings about these things they uh say
no no humans were around at the same
time as the dinosaurs you know that was
65 million years ago what can we say you
know uh it uh I can't take these people
seriously but yeah they believe these
things and I don't know what to tell
them okay okay um here's another fellow
says something about that he says there
is no precedent for intelligent human
life being becoming extinct also the
motivating uh factor for production
historically has not always been
monetary compensation when economics uh
fall apart or when econom economies fall
apart the zealots take power well uh the
first I'm just going to address the
first part of that
uh the we're the only intelligent
humans that been around but there's
other hominids you know like the
Neanderthals they've been around they
were pretty intelligent and they're no
longer around so they be did become
extinct and before them the the uh what
is it the hyob bgs you know hyob bensis
homo hyob bensis and before that
homoerectus and Homo habilis and you got
them all the whole line they've all
disappeared at some point and so what
can I tell you you
know um again uh I I cannot speak for
every everybody has different facts or
different makes different assumptions
and if you have a very irrational
assumption or your assumption doesn't
match the record at all or you're
challenging the record but a record that
there's no reason to
challenge uh well then you're going to
end up with with a different Theory and
your theory may not be very irrational
because your starting point was not very
good okay all I can say is think about
that and uh last Point here I want to
make fell says we agree with Jeffrey's
general theory of Stellar metamorphosis
the general idea anyway uh this does not
really have to do with Extinction it has
to do with Creation with where do we
come from you know but it's part of the
life cycle you know beginning and end
you know Alpha and Omega and uh no
Jeffrey did not come up with that okay
uh and for those of you who want to
understand what this fell is talking
about I made a video uh 20 number 25
there Earth is older than the sun you
can look it up uh in my other channel my
main Channel um there I wrote a um uh or
pointed to that link and you can read o
paren paper uh 1926
and he's the guy who came up with the
so-called uh theory of Stell
metamorphosis which uh Jeff relabeled
okay and so
uh just a
moment um and so this Stellar uh
Metamorphoses does not originate with um
with Jeff okay that's all I want to say
and with that I'll be moving to the next
topic which is
um gravitational constant
G what is the general the gravitational
constant G well we're talking about
we're talking about um not the
mathematics of it we're really not
interested in the mathematics we're not
going to do problems here put numbers in
there and try to calculate something
we're trying to figure out um what is
the meaning of the equation what does it
represent okay uh especially in physical
terms here we do physics we don't do
math okay but uh we're going to analyze
the um uh the the variables that are
included in that uh value and also in
the equations that we're going to look
at here especially Newton against
Einstein so uh here we had the two
Champions one is uh Newton on the left
and Einstein on the right and they both
use G gravitational constant G in their
um respective equations okay and so
let's look at this what does g mean I
mean why did they put that in there what
what is the physical significance of
that letter G
okay and we start with this we're
showing that this is what what the issue
is or one of at least probably the main
issue okay and that is you have the Sun
and the Earth and the question that
everybody wants answered is why doesn't
the Earth fly spontaneously fly away
from uh the sun okay uh what I mean
what's holding it to the Sun why does it
keep rolling around in circles around
the Sun and that's going to relate to
this gravitational constant G
okay um and we'll look at uh the
different equations here here's Newton's
equation okay and he says well it's mass
mass divided by distance squared the r
stands for radius radius square okay
because it's to the center of whatever
spherical object you're referring to in
this case you have the distance really
from the center of the earth to the
center of the Sun but irrelevant really
to some degree uh what we're saying is
you have mass mass distance and uh why
put the letter G why did newon put the
letter g in there well it turn he didn't
you know and in fact he doesn't have a
single equation in his famous book
principia okay what he has is an
explanation and there's a reason for
that and the reason is he had no values
for the mass of the Sun the mass of the
Earth the mass of the Moon okay the the
things that he talked about so he had no
values and so he really there was no
reason for him to put really an equation
he explained it um qualitatively
right which is the way physics should be
done okay but what was important is that
and here you see uh his notion of how he
pictured this what what was going
through his mind he said look you know
uh you have these particles because you
know they all believed in The Ether and
what is The Ether The Ether is a bunch
of particles and ether is don't
understand it even to this day but yeah
that's what the ether is a bunch of
particles and the only difference
between Newton and the wave folks uh
such as hins and um Robert Hook was that
these other fellas said The Ether waved
up and down whereas Newton said go
straight okay that was the difference
between them but they all believed in
The Ether what was The Ether a bunch of
particles okay but then he could not
explain with this how you know the Earth
was physically tied to the sun he could
not explain it in fact he says the
following okay this is a famous quote
from him in a letter
uh to uh Bentley okay he says uh uh it's
conceivably that inanimate brute matter
should without the mediation of
something else which is not Material
right operate upon and affect other
matter without Mutual contact that one
body may act upon another at a distance
through a vacuum without the mediation
of anything else by and through which
their action or force be conveyed from
one to another is to me so great an
absurdity that no man can fall into it
he say and gravity must be caused by an
agent acting
constantly and so he could not explain
it with his particles because he was
thinking of particles and that's one of
the problems that eventually spelled his
Doom okay because um you know he he he
was thinking in terms of particles but
when we get to the 20th century they
said well you know we we cannot explain
it with particles especially particles
coming one way I mean the only way a
discrete particle can fly or travel is
in a single Direction how do you pull on
a donkey by throwing you know stones at
it well you can't and that was the
problem he had he had no mechanism to
explain gravity oh he said look I've got
the equation mass mass divided distance
squared that he could understand but he
could not understand the physical
mechanism okay so up comes uh Einstein
you know 1915 he writes his general
relativity equation what was the
important thing about that the important
thing is uh that he introduces the field
the notion of a field um into gravity
and he's saying look it's a field
equation and what is a field well a
field is really a bunch of numbers
that's all a field is a value at each
point in space it doesn't matter how
close one point is to the another each
one has a distinct value of gravity
gravitational value but what is the
sense the physical sense of that well
the physical sense is a field is is
thought of as a continuous
sheet canvas
fishnet right we have a continuous sheet
Dependable right and so suddenly instead
of particles flying from the Sun to the
Earth or vice versa or both ways right
what we have is a a platform you know
there's a trampoline there's a uh canvas
a fishnet underneath both bodies and
they weigh it down and so it's
continuous and now gravity is going to
propagate against along the socalled
field okay that's that's the notion
these people had okay and so here it is
okay this is Einstein's original
equation up there uh more or less it's a
different version of it but it doesn't
matter they're all the same really and
it says relate SpaceTime curvature to
the stress energy of a system well we
have a problem because you know what do
you mean uh the curvature of space and
what do you mean the curvature of time
what does that mean how do you curve
time so the physical interpretation is
totally irrational all you can do is
talk about mathematics and this is more
or less uh a way of presenting
mathematics in some way that you can
relate it to physics but it ain't
because the whole notion of what they're
talking about curvature of time doesn't
make any sense whatsoever so you cannot
turn your math into physics just by
using these fancy words okay that's the
issue then you have um there you have
others one is the amount of energy or
the fabric of space what do you mean the
fabric of space space is not a fabric
space is nothing so to say the fabric of
space is an irrational statement because
it doesn't match you know the real world
uh amount of energy well what is energy
well to this point to this day as I've
shown before nobody's defined the word
energy no one knows what an energy is uh
Richard pinan Nobel Prize of in 1965
famously said we have no idea what
energy is yeah then you have another one
properties of every Point within
SpaceTime you have another variable
there uh product of constants and the
last one energy momentum and stress
that's what that equation's talking
about what are they talking about in the
last one there they're talking about
really this notion they have of dark
energy okay and uh which Ein said was
his biggest blunder because he wasn't
able to make sense of it when he did
wrote his equation for the first time
what is dark energy what's uh that
thingy that ocean that Medium that is
pushing everything apart since the days
of the Big Bang 13.8 billion years ago
so you have this expansion of space time
right and it's all being pushed by this
physical entity they call Dark Energy
when energy is a concept an undefined
concept nobody knows what energy is but
that's what they use it's like saying X
and you say well what do you mean by X
we don't know what we mean by X but
that's what's pushing everything out
it's whatever it's pushing everything
out that's what we call X that's what
they call Dark Energy okay okay so um
talked about a tensor there what is a
tensor just so people know here in
general relativity the presence of mass
and energy causes space what time to
curve they cause time to curve how do
you turn Cur how do you curve time this
curvature is described not explained but
described by the metric tensor so you're
talking about a uh quantitative analysis
of something and they're going to
describe it and they're not going to
explain what it is because they have no
clue okay which encodes information
about how distances and angles change in
curved time again we have curved time
um all over the place they're curving
time they're bending time okay and there
you have the tensor at the bottom gives
you an idea okay it's just a more
sophisticated Matrix that's all it is
okay so you see the Matrix here just one
two three four and what's a tensor well
it's a more sophisticated one where you
have one two on one in one block three
two on the other 17 54 that's called a
tensor so it's just a more complex
Matrix that's all it is and it says
their tensors are coordinate independent
mathematical what objects what do you
mean objects what's an object this means
that the equations and relationships
involving tensors hold true regardless
of the coordinate system chosen to
describe space time and vectors on the
other hand are coordinate dependent okay
so that's essentially the difference
between a matrix and a uh I'm sorry
between a vector and a tensor okay so uh
we don't care about all that gibberish
okay because we're interested in uh
physical interpretation we're doing
physics here not math okay and so what's
the bottom line well this is what they
came up with they said look here's the
Sun and here's the Earth okay and what
we have really here is that the um uh
Earth doesn't fly away because there's
this canvas this field this continuous
entity this continuous ocean so to speak
and when the uh Sun weighs it down it
curves it you're curving time there
because those white lines that you see
there that um fishnet it's space time we
don't know what the black stuff is
because that can't be space space time
is the net so uh keep that in mind but
anyways uh the sun weighs down the
SpaceTime canvas and that prevents the
Earth from flying out of the solar
system okay so um what is Einstein
saying essentially or
his his followers today essentially it's
a roulette system okay very easy to
understand you have the sun there and it
creates this warped uh region around it
and the Earth doesn't have any choice
but to go around because it encounters a
wall of warped space time that prevents
the Earth from leaving the solar system
uh of course when you point that out to
the mathematicians they say well you're
taking the analogy too literally and uh
etc etc it's just philosophy we don't
care about that we care about the math
if they only care about the math why
don't you stick to math and forget about
physics try forget about giving a
physical interpretation to something
that you don't understand and that you
cannot explain because they give these
physical interpretations when you point
to them that it's irrational and say oh
you're taking it too literally and
that's philosophy anyways so why are you
doing philosophy if it's not your job
Des not in your job description it's
it's not your field of work that's the
issue they should be doing physical
interpretations and they have no idea
what uh what they're talking about okay
especially if they talk about warp time
what the hell is
that okay um so uh here we have um Mr
Wheeler and he synthesizes for us
Einstein's equation which includes the
gravitational constant G by the way and
says F says SpaceTime tells matter how
to move matter tells SpaceTime how to
curve that's in a nutshell what
Einstein's equation means from a
physical point of view except that you
know they they say you know tell time
essentially tells matter how to move no
time cannot tell matter how to move and
matter cannot do anything to time
especially curve it so it's the physical
interpretation which is irrational so
whatever they come up with these
synthesis uh doesn't explain anything it
doesn't tell us anything about what's
going on in the physical world in the
real world okay out there that's the
issue and so these people are kidding
themselves when they say that these are
the physical
interpretations um and more so when they
actually a lot of them believe them they
say yeah yeah it actually works and
they'll tell you that we've proven it it
warps uh because otherwise GPS wouldn't
work and blah blah blah you know a lot
of stuff like that
nonsense uh this is more or less uh what
Einstein was saying he saying you know
when you take a step like he did it with
Mercury and he says look we're different
than Newton not only in the fact that
Newton just has these particles going
from the Sun to the Earth somehow
keeping keeping it faithful uh to to the
sun he did it with Mercury you know uh
but that's one issue but the other issue
is that um Einstein his equation because
it's a field equation he says every step
that mercury takes it also bends
SpaceTime and the Sun is also going
around the Milky Way so it's is also
bending another SpaceTime and so what
happens this Mutual interaction causes
the uh canvas to um change to change its
shape okay and here uh here I'll show
you a simulation of that so you can see
what I'm talking about you have these
kids and you can see when they take a
step it bends the trampoline and that
causes them to take a different kind of
Step than they would if if that thing
was you know solid
straight you know without bending but by
bending their next move is going to be
different and it's different for all the
other uh kids in other words all the
other planets right um You you move the
the canvas and it changes the canvas uh
the shape of the canvas and that forces
you to move in a different way and other
things to move in a different way as
well and that's more or less the notion
that uh Einstein had for his field
equation he says look Mercury is ending
SpaceTime and that's going to cause the
next motion of mercury to be different
especially when the moon when the sun
does exactly the same thing okay so
everything is dynamic and they like the
mathematicians eventually like that
because they like that they could
explain that a little better you know
with a field notion than with Newton's
particles and that's Force you know and
so they dro the particles the force and
they said no we're going to go with
space time we think that's a better
physical interpretation that we can
relate to and we have the math to
support it uh which they said is a
little more accurate than Newton's and
uh yeah in fact new uh Einstein's
equation said to approach Newton's at
the limit and you can see why because
Einstein's is a dynamic equation whereas
Newton's is a static equation you're not
talking about distance traveled in the
case of Newton's equation you're talking
about the distance of physics separation
so it's a static notion and yeah when
when you take new uh Einstein's Mo uh uh
moving or
dynamic uh
equation at the limit at location it
matches new no kidding yeah it's got to
because Mo motion you know the limit of
motion is
location okay very in physics okay in
rational physics in uh math you know
they say well it's the we take the limit
and we approach Newton's equation okay
whatever anyways here we have um start
with Newton's again see if we can find
out what this gravitational constant G
is okay and Newton did not put it in
there in fact he was not able to
calculate it again because he didn't
have the masses of the Sun the Earth the
moon and any other
um what is it the
um celestial objects um in the solar
system so he just gave us the physical
interpretation in fact um the um uh
equation was solved by someone else uh
the gravitational constant G came in
later when they uh started doing some
measurements and calculations they said
we're going to need this gravitational
constant G that's where we're getting at
and so here's where we start we say look
we have a man standing on the earth okay
and uh so how's Newton going to
calculate this uh you know uh the
gravity or the uh force of gravity right
why is there such and such acceleration
and this is more or less how Newton
comes up with it he says look uh and
really this came after Newton but I
we'll uh attribute it to Newton okay we
have mass times mass divided by distance
squared and we have to multiply times
the gravitational constant G but what if
we took the G out okay let's assume
there was no G what would we get in that
case and here you see the the problem
you see that you would get the force of
gravity is kilogram squ over met squar
and what the hell does that mean you
know what is kilogram squ over meter squ
well what interpretation can you give to
that so what happened they put the
gravitational constant G why because it
was put in there by hand it was at hoc
okay they had no idea they just needed
the units to put in there and that's
that's how this came about uh you can
see there if you put uh the
gravitational constant G which is meter
cubed divided kilogram second squared if
you put that in that uh Force equation
well you cancel out the meter cubed with
a meter squared leaving meter at the top
okay and you cancel the kilogram squared
at the top divided by kilogram at the
bottom that gives you kilogram at the
top and second eventually second square
at the bottom and you end up with what
is known as the Newton which is the um
the unit of force okay still makes very
little sense because they say well it's
a one k kog per meter per second per
second that's what a newton is okay
whatever that means to you okay but
that's that's the notion they had but
they had to put in these values by hand
okay and yeah based on that you were
able to calculate you know not only the
force of gravity uh especially here on
Earth you can calculate the acceleration
of gravity you know these sort of things
but that's great but what does g mean I
mean what is that strange unit that
weird unit that he just put in there and
so we go to The Experts okay when we
will try to answer these sophisticated
questions you have to go to The Experts
so we have here the phds under the stack
exchange and they tell you exactly what
it means in physical terms so someone
asked a question what is the physical
meaning and origin of the gravitational
constant G and here's the answer it says
it is just a value to fix the units in
the equation so it was put in there by
hand okay there is no physical content
to its value other than to describe the
size of the unit of mass compared to the
units of length and time so it was put
in there by hand these people had to put
these units in there so that the
equation came out right what does it
represent in general relativity Theory
well the answer simply a unit of
conversion usually we simply get rid of
it by using units such as C velocity
your light Square velocity or right
equals gravitational constant uh equal
one and and does it have any physical
meaning or physical origin no or rather
no physical meaning beyond the choice of
units okay so there's your answer uh
what does uh the gravitational constant
g mean in uh mathematical physics in
general relativity means absolutely
nothing they have no idea what it means
they just put the units because it helps
them calculate but they have no way of
relating that to the physical world
that's the issue okay okay so here we
start with uh our version of it um Y is
mass mass divided by distance squared
here it is okay this what it looks like
uh every atom of that man's body we're
just going to take only one atom at the
end of his toe okay and it's connected
to every atom on Earth through
electromagnetic ropes which is the
mediator uh of gravity and of light and
every atom in the universe is connected
to all others so we have one atom there
connected to every atom on Earth and of
course I did not draw all the uh atom
but you can appreciate what's happening
here as an astronaut Falls to Earth you
know the uh ropes widen out they fan out
and so his
acceleration uh is greater as he falls
there there is an acceleration of
gravity and you can see why because as
he approaches the Earth you know the
distance becomes uh less and less it
decreases then uh the guy has pulled at
a faster and faster rate okay so that's
our explanation but we still haven't
explained you know the gravitational
constant G all we're explaining is mass
mass divided by distance squared okay
that's so let's keep that in mind so we
had this value it comes from um
Cavendish and uh really good old
Cavendish should not take the uh uh
credit for it for building his uh well
maybe for building his uh torsion
balance uh the guy who came up with that
was John Mitchell but John Mitchell died
five years before this fellow was able
to publish his uh experiment and that's
how how he came up with the value for
the gravitational constant G and this is
what it looks like today okay here
you'll see it okay you have
um two weights and you let uh another
pair of Weights hanging from a little um
thing that connects them and they're
tied in by a little thread going to the
ceiling and you can see over time uh one
weight approaches uh the one closest to
it the other one approaches the other
and it's this torsion on the U on the
string on the thread that connects them
it's that torsion which is measured okay
and this is essentially the force of
gravity because you can see that uh it's
not a downward gravity it's a sideways
gravity one Mass is attracted to another
Mass so to speak which is you know
Newton's equation okay mass mass
distance squared and the closer they get
the faster they go okay you'll see that
there of course it's very difficult to
measure because it's a crude experiment
but yeah they they go faster and faster
and
faster okay so that's how they
calculated the gravitational constant G
okay we have a value and the
units by hand because they needed those
units okay to make sure that the
equation checks out okay okay so here we
have the the gravitational constanty we
have it there uh
667 uh *
10-1 Newtons meter squar over kilogram
squared what in the world does all that
mean well the Newton is a kilogram meter
over second squared okay and so when you
uh look at that it comes out to 667 / by
10 11th um um kilog met cubed over kilog
s second squared you cancel out
kilograms there and you end up with a
unit of the Newton which is meter uh I'm
sorry with unit of gravitational
constant G which is meter cubed over
kilogram second squared and still we
have no idea what that means okay um you
know what does that unit represent
because it's a single unit meter cub
kilog gr second squar what does that
what can that possibly mean and one of
the problems we have is that these
people try to synthesize it and make it
even as uh as smaller or as synthetic as
they can possibly get it and here you
see this is the end result of their work
okay and uh sometimes they make it even
worse by saying oh it's uh so many
newtons okay instead of meter cubed
kilogram second squar they put they put
it in terms of Newtons and what they
done really is uh Cloud themselves or
blind Blindside themselves to the
problem they they blindsided themselves
to the solution of what the
gravitational constant G represents in
physical terms if they would have left
it as it was they probably would have
figured it out but they never will
because they synthesize and synthesize
and synthesize to get it ever ever more
efficient and here we don't need
efficiency we need exactly the opposite
we need to know exact exactly in a crude
way what these numbers what these units
represent okay so here's the
gravitational constant according to
science to physics to the Rope model
okay so we're going to put the numbers
first there we're going to justify them
okay so here we have it uh we take that
667 101 uh Meer cubed kilogram second
squared and we bring it to where you see
number one there okay that's the same
value there meter cube over kilogram
second squared okay and and then we go
to number two we're going to multiply
that that value the G by 10 the 16
kilogram over 10 to the 16 kilogram in
other words we're going to multiply
times one so we've committed no crime
this is just straight mathematics okay
and now when we do the multiplication
there we end up with number three there
667 * 10 16 over 10^ the 27 and uh an
impossible number you know we don't even
know what that's all about but once we
look at uh what it could represent we
find out that it does make sense we find
that uh 1.67 over 10 27 is the mass of
the hydrogen atom which is the unit of
mass that mother nature uses that's the
smallest unit of ma of matter there's
nothing below that because below that
it's not called matter okay under the
Rope model okay and then you multiply
times the velocity of light squared
which ends up being 9 * 10 to the 16th
there and now yes we can
eliminate uh two big factors one is the
hydrogen the mass of the hydrogen atom
the other one is the velocity of light
squared and we're going to multiply it
times that um remainder there
0.544 meters over kilograms we're not
going to go over that one anyone who
wants to understand that one will have
to read my book where I because it's
several paragraphs to explain that okay
uh anyways it's in my book
it's not that I'm copying out uh but
what I want you to understand instead is
uh why it's um the hydrogen atom and why
its velocity of light squared okay why
that's the case why that gives you the
force of gravity okay which is what
we're looking for here and there it is
okay every atom is connected to every
atom in the universe by electromagnetic
ropes they torque the rope and the
signal but goes in both directions from
one hydrogen atom to all atoms in the
universe and from all atoms in the
universe to our test or our hydrogen
atom that's what's happening so you have
light travels in both directions
simultaneously from one atom to every
atom and from every atom to our atom
okay and so uh that gives you an idea
why uh the gravitational constant G
contains the hydrogen the mass of the
hydrogen atom and also the velocity of
light squared okay it just means that
light travels in two directions okay
under the Rope model uh in uh quantum
mechanics in general relativity in
mathematical physics and in string
theory light only travels in One
Direction because it's uh mediated by
photons what are photons well supposedly
they're cor pusles but they're not even
that they're just a bunch of numbers
they're just
they don't have a physical
interpretation for light what they have
is numbers okay and so they have all
these numbers traveling in One Direction
only because they look at values that's
all they're looking at so they're
looking at amounts values quantities
that's all they're looking at here we're
saying no there's a physical entity
between any two atoms it torch the Rope
okay that's the mediator and because it
Tores the Rope like travels in both
directions simultaneously you can prove
that to yourself you know proof evidence
uh by taking a Rob and just turling it
any direction you want you'll see that
the signal really travels in both
directions both atoms receive a signal
it's a round trip for both okay and what
is it from one hydrogen atom to another
hydrogen atom that's why you have to
have the mass of the hydrogen atom which
has been measured to
-27 uh range so that gives you an idea
what the gravitational constant
represents from a physical point of view
and uh the remaining 0.44 meter per
kilogram that's uh take it as
homework
okay okay let's go with some of the
questions people asked okay uh things
they brought up here's one of them says
here's my respond to The Ether challenge
when F fell says oh good we always want
challenges here please show the Phantom
thread ether picture on your next
broadcast so everyone understands what I
mean and this is what the fell Drew he
drew what I think are Adams there and
he's got a thread blue thread going
through all of them and then we have
some black stuff in the background okay
so we have three things there three
things that we have to justify and so I
cannot tell you which one is the ether
maybe the ether is the black stuff maybe
the ether is the blue stuff maybe the
ether is the white stuff we don't know
because he did not label them but um uh
the question is why does he use the word
ether we have a thread we have the atoms
and we have the black stuff which we
call space uh in rational science so we
have three different things where's The
Ether what does the e word ether have to
do with any of this okay ether is a
bunch of particles and a bunch of
particles is not what we're seeing here
we're seeing particles uh the if you
call the atoms a particle we're seeing
black stuff and we're seeing a thread
going through all of them so we have
three things and what does this have to
do with the word ether and again he
would have to Define Define or start by
defining the word ether or tell us what
he means by Ether before he can put a
picture there and that was the challenge
he just put a picture there and say see
there I I proved it well what can I say
he hasn't done much work uh he's got a
label and he's got to show us exactly
what he means by each one of those which
one is the ether of all of them and why
he's using the word ether for that he's
got to define the word ether or paint a
picture of it you know right now we have
a picture of three things
and not a picture of one thing which you
would think is this
ether okay another fell says uh the
following he says uh what causes the
process of compression of the sun
transformation into heavier material or
perhaps cooling uh we discussed how the
Sun compresses you know every atom
hydrogen last time right uh compresses
compresses compresses and um the
difference we have with the
establishment we believe INF Fusion as
well we think that's how the sun
produces heat and uh energy you know
whatever it's called whatever energy is
it produces um this heat this uh this um
this
uh signal that comes out through the
ropes right and produces by compressing
atoms but the difference we have with
the establishment is while the
establishment says that the particles in
the middle of the sun are moving around
because they have all this room to move
around they move at Great speeds and
they crash or Collide against each other
we're saying that's not what's happening
what's happening is they're compressed
one against the other there is no motion
or very little Motion in the center of
the sun because everything's being
compressed compressed compressed and
again our atom is a u is like a ball of
yarn it looks more or less like this
okay this is what it what it would look
like if you saw it you know straight on
it's a ball of yarn okay and uh what it
is is is you know the
um um the threads weaving especially the
surface of the hydrogen of the hydrogen
atomine the electron shell and it's
these shells which are compressed
against each other forming uh higher
elements like helium first and lithium
and so on Down the Line okay so it's
compression but what is that compression
it's the pressure remember you're
everything's attracted towards the
center in gravity that's why Newton's
equation works because uh you take the
center of a spherical object as the
source of gravity meaning that's where
everything com um uh is pointed towards
okay that's in the direction in which
everything travels towards the center
and that's what's happening every atom
is just pressing pressing pressing
pressing in the sun squeezing the atoms
in the center one against the other
that's our notion of that so we do agree
with the establishment that it's caused
by Fusion that's why uh um it's you know
long lasting unlike a match you light up
a match well it doesn't last very long
that's not what's happening in the
center of the sun it's not a match what
it is is compression and what's being
released is torsion along the ropes of
every atom of the sun that's connected
to everything else in the universe
including the Earth so we receive the
frequency and wavelength along the Rope
what is it torsion okay so that's our
notion okay F says if the electron
supposedly rotates constantly around the
nucleus then it is a perpetual motion
machine uh yes and no under quantum
mechanics it's not because uh the notion
they have in mathematical physics is
that the universe will one day end in a
big crunch uh it's going to or or
everything just disappear years uh
slowly you know disintegrates and goes
out so that means that at some point not
even the electrons will remain and in
that sense it's not
Perpetual it's long lasting maybe but
not Perpetual in mathematical physics in
uh the Rope model it is Perpetual why
because the universe is this that's the
universe a single closed loop thread
like a rubber band but it doesn't
stretch it's a single closo thread uh
made of a single piece it does not uh
extend it's not expand doesn't uh change
um in other words it doesn't stretch
okay that's the main point it's not like
a rubber band it's a single thread and
that weaves every atom in the universe
and the ropes that interconnector very
simple universe that we live in it was
never created and it can never be
uncreated it cannot disappear it cannot
be turned into empty space which is
nothing which is that which has no shape
so that which has shape cannot suddenly
convert spontaneously into that which
has no shape unless you can tell me what
the mechanism is and I'll even concede
if you want to put God in there put God
in there as well I want to see the
mechanism of how God converts something
into
nothing that which has shape into that
which doesn't have shape in zero time
because you're talking about you know
from one frame to the other whatever
time you want to give that gazillions of
a second you know it doesn't matter the
point is you cannot convert one into the
other from one frame of the universal
movie to another okay so yeah our
universe is perpetual and therefore the
atoms are Perpetual in the Rope model
not in quantum mechanics general
relativity or strength theory meaning
mathematical physics because the
universe will end whether in a crunch or
just
dissolving by expanding forever and at
some point even Adams stopped existing
according to the official version
catechism okay and the final one FS says
he beats me up here he says you don't
care for any other physical mechanism
but yours so why are you
asking well no the issue here is that um
my opinions don't matter they don't
matter I I can criticize hopefully I'm
allowed to criticize Free Speech you
know any uh the out there any proposal
uh the issue is can you explain
something if you explain something we
will gladly analyze it if it's rational
we'll give you credit if it's irrational
we'll beat you up that's just that
simple it's not that uh we we don't
allow people to talk you can say
whatever you want if you if you have a
theory of something we will discuss it
we discuss all people who have proposals
here their Notions of The Ether we'
discussed everything we don't shy away
from any question question or any
comment that we think is pertinent and
we're going to address it so if you have
a theory uh put it on there don't say oh
bill but you don't believe in any except
your own okay so it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I
believe uh science is not about belief
science is not about criticism science
is about explaining please explain if
you are a scientist or consider yourself
a scientist with that I'll see you next
week okay we'll see you then byebye yeah